there are basic
fundamental questions that have to be
asked of every elected official
and they often are not being asked and a
british sky news journalist confronted
texas republican senator ted cruz
yesterday and asked him
very obvious and specific questions
about the gun violence problem in the
united states ted cruz didn't like it he
accused the guy of playing politics and
he walked away
uh sky news is no left-wing bomb
throwing network sky news is the british
version of fox news let's take a look at
what happened and not unwelcome there
are 19 sets of parents
who are never going to get to kiss
their child tonight
thank you
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important by the way
this this is a this is a focus group
tested technique
if anyone ever brings up gun policy
you pejoratively say that that's
politics that's politics and politics is
bad and it's the wrong time for politics
this is just a tool it's a crutch that
they use but the reporter is not going
to be dissuaded the heart of the issue i
i get that that's where the media likes
to go and so that's the second layer of
the attack okay ted cruz is doing all
the right things from the point of view
of republican disinformation if anyone
asks about guns you call it politics if
they press you you say this is what the
media likes to do because the media is
bad if you're a republican okay but the
reporter is not going to be dissuaded
it's not it's where many of the people
we've talked to here like to go the
proposals from democrats in the media
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two
ar-15s if you want to stop
violent cry
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this well
actually
i gave a list of 10 ideas at the top of
the show
four of which would have potentially had
an impact in this particular case but
they don't want to try any of them why
does this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism
so awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's
honestly yeah the political agenda of
right wing sky news the british version
of fox i mean truly a pathetic coward
i'd love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem why is this
just an american problem now another
reporter jumps in
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
not shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why is it
that people come from by the way now he
starts pointing at at the guy's chest
with the finger all over the world to
america because it's the freest most
prosperous safest country maybe
it may be the free maybe the most why
are our kids dying
if that wasn't clear enough the
governor's earlier news
yeah
um
when is the time for politics out of
curiosity like what i mean by that is no
matter when you try to talk about guns
they say this is not the trump the the
time for politics we need these direct
questions
that was not some left-wing bomb
throwing network that was sky news
and now on friday or saturday ted cruz
will be at the nra convention saying oh
we got to say a prayer and we've got to
make sure that we keep our right to
defend ourselves good job by the sky
news reporter and um these are the exact
types of questions they need to be asked
and that they would hopefully be forced
to answer
one of our sponsors is crush organics
these guys are awesome they support the
show they have an excellent collection
of premium grade organic cbd products
crush organics has your oils your
topical creams gummies they even have
these great experience gift boxes which
are great for sending to someone this is
the one i received really beautifully
packaged crush has a daytime cbd blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report cbd being
helpful for sleep crush's cbd topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great some people prefer the gummies
over the oils crush organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your cbd from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to the site and crush organics
are fans of the david pakman show just
like you i hope so they're giving you a
massive discount 40
off all products go to crush organics
dot us and use the code pacman to save
40 percent the link is down below